wir gehen erst mal dahin wo die
flüchtlingskrise tatsächlich passiert in
die kommunen in die städte nach dormagen
wir schauen uns einmal an wie dort
aktuell flüchtlingskrise aussieht
märz 2022
in deutschland werden aus turnhallen und
schulen wieder flüchtlingsunterkünfte
aus bürgermeistern wieder
flüchtlingsbeauftragte wie hier in
dormagen in den letzten tagen mit
hunderten von ehrenamtlern und auch mit
unseren kollegen und kollegen von der
stadt von der feuerwehr mit dem
hilfsorganisation malteser dlrg haben
wir es geschafft hier diese einrichtung
aufzuziehen das haben wir unterm strich
innerhalb von drei tagen geschaffen mehr
als 300 flüchtlinge aus der ukraine sind
hier angekommen vor allem kinder mit
behinderungen bürgermeister erik
lierenfeld hat ja gesagt ja zu diesen
kindern helfen anpacken ohne zu wissen
wie das alles zu schaffen ist also
realistischerweise glaube ich dass es
schwierig wird die menschen jetzt im
wohnraum unterzubringen werden jetzt
massiv daran arbeiten wohnungen
aufzubauen wir haben auch bereits über
200 menschen in privaten unterkünften
untergebracht aber das ist alles auch
nur auf zeit auch dort ist die situation
dass die menschen sich mit anderen
menschen die häuser wohnungen teilen und
ich glaube dass die unterbringung in
solchen unterkünften schon für deutlich
längere zeit notwendig sein wird als wir
das vielleicht aus der zeit 2015 kennen
also baut er die nächste tonhalle zur
flüchtlingsunterkunft um
als die dritte in seiner stadt
toilettencontainer stückpreis 35.000
euro wie viele noch davon niemand weiß
es
und jetzt ist das bei uns
herzlich willkommen man dem
bürgermeister von dorma lierenfeld wenn
sie uns da gerade zeigen wie sie sofort
bereit waren zu helfen diesen kindern
die speziell zu ihnen gekommen sind
viele mit behinderungen mit geistigen
mit körperlichen behinderungen also das
ist eine besondere aufgabe besondere
herausforderungen für sie sie haben
sofort ja gesagt wer hat ihnen denn
geholfen damit sie helfen können haben
sie genug hilfe bekommen zum helfen
ja also sie haben eben die frage
gestellt schaffen wir das oder wir
schaffen das und da muss man zunächst
einmal fragen wie definiert sich dass
wir und in der tat sind wir da in den
kommunen doch weitestgehend auf uns
alleingestellt also ich kann auch meine
vorredner nicht ich sag jetzt mal
bestätigen bei dem hinweis dass wir
darauf gut vorbereitet sind weil man
muss wissen bevor diese situation jetzt
über uns gekommen ist haben wir bereits
viele menschen untergebracht allein in
dormagen haben über 1350 menschen
bereits untergebracht das heißt die
einrichtungen die wir seit 2005 10
aufgebaut haben die sind voll also
mussten wir jetzt sehr schnell handeln
und da helfen uns tatsächlich die
ehrenamtlich engagierten
die hilfsorganisation ich kann da auf
eine sehr große breite schichten der
bevölkerung bauen und ohne diese
menschen hätten wir jetzt schon in den
letzten tagen probleme gehabt und eben
ist die zahl von 300 genannt worden wir
haben zum ende des tages wahrscheinlich
schon fast 500 menschen die wir alleine
dormagen unterbringen mussten für die
wir hier einfach schauen müssen dass die
versorgt werden dass die genug leitung
haben weil die menschen die zu uns
kommen haben wirklich gar nichts und von
daher ich kann den hinweis von frau
teuteberg was die registrierung angeht
zwar nachvollziehen aber das ist
tatsächlich wenn sie erstmal gucken
müssen dass die leute wollten dach überm
kopf haben ist dass das was gerade
vorgeht was fehlt ihnen denn ganz
konkret an hilfe also wo bräuchten sie
hilfe wo sie sich im moment
ausschließlich selbst helfen können
ja also bei der frage wie wir die
menschen unterbringen wie wir gebäude
bauen wie wir an betten kommen das sind
alles dinge da würde ich mir natürlich
ich mich freuen wenn es da irgendwie von
einer zentralen stelle vom land oder
sonstwo unterstützung gebe dass man
irgendwo dinge eingelagert hätte
vielleicht weil es ist wie 2015 das habe
ich alles wieder das ist ein déjà vu für
mich quasi dass wir eigenständig
unterwegs sind die dinge organisieren
und was ganz wichtig ist das thema
verteilung ich würde mir wünschen dass
man wirklich darauf schaut dass die
menschen in den hauptbahnhöfen ankommen
sind die großen hauptbahnhöfe wo die
menschen ankommen dass man von dort
wirklich eine registrierung vielleicht
organisiert durch die mittelbehörden und
auch landesbehörden und dann erst die
verteilung auf die kommunen vornimmt das
ist gerät im moment noch auf zuruf so
habe ich das zumindest hier erlebt am
berliner hauptbahnhof haben wir gerade
in dem kurzen film über dormagen schon
gehört da werden jetzt wieder turnhallen
zu flüchtlingsunterkünften bei ihnen
auch drei sportteilen so hatten sie uns
das gesagt wie ist das in der
bevölkerung aktuell das bedeutet ja
möglicherweise auch wieder das wird in
vielen städten der fall sein dann kein
sportunterricht oder halt woanders wird
wieder kompliziert für die bevölkerung
das wahrscheinlich auf lange sicht jetzt
der krieg wirklich morgen nicht in der
nächsten woche enden und wie wird das
bei ihnen doch mal in dormagen
aufgenommen
zunächst mal muss man erklären warum
nehmen wir turnhalle war dort einfach
schon eine infrastruktur ist mit duschen
und toiletten die sie sonst nicht haben
das ist die große schwierigkeit wir
diese container wie wenn sie noch welche
bekommen die kosten jetzt schon wieder
ein vielfaches auch da gibt es nichts
vorrätig und das ist das problem
die menschen nehmen das hier gut auf wir
haben eine riesen solidität auch hier in
der bevölkerung ich lade auch immer
viele menschen ein vorort sich die
einrichtung anzuschauen wenn sie die
kinder sehen und die mütter sehen was
für probleme die haben dann wissen sie
auch okay wir müssen im zweifel jetzt
mal den schulsport im klassenraum machen
oder wenn das wetter besser ist
rausgehen weil die turnhalle vielleicht
gerade von menschen belegt ist die jetzt
auf wenigen quadratmetern also wir haben
die familien wirklich er immer in räumen
untergebracht also auch in der turnhalle
haben wir richtige räume gebaut kabinen
die abschließbaren damit eine gewisse
privatsphäre üblich sehr auf turnhallen
in anderen städten da liegt feldbett
nehmen fällt mir da haben wir vielleicht
ein bauzaun dazwischen das halte ich
nicht für adäquat für eine unterbringung
von familien mit kindern das ist für
mich eine sehr sehr schwierige forschung
aktuell wie viele könnten sie doch
aufnehmen kann man das sagen in dormagen
wenn sie die wunsch infrastruktur
bekommen oder platzen sie im grunde
jetzt schon aus allen nähten und das
war's mir können sie nicht
wenn sie uns vor beginn des kriegs
gefragt hätten wie viele können sie
aufnehmen hätten wir gesagt 10 aktuell
habe ich eben schon gesagt haben wir
fast 500 aufgenommen das heißt wir
machen das unmögliche möglich und das
wird auch in den nächsten wochen zu sein
wir haben eine fiktive zahl
beziehungsweise eine einmal kann die
zeit unterbrechen wenn eine million
menschen nach deutschland kommen kommen
da von 812 nach dormagen das kann man
mit den schlüsseln berechnen wenn man
zuletzt davon ausgegangen ist das
vielleicht sogar bis zu vier millionen
menschen nach deutschland kommen könnten
sprechen wir hier von 3200 menschen die
nach dormagen kommen das sind zahlen die
wir schon bauchschmerzen machen weil bei
all den dingen die wir aktuell planen
haben wir kapazitäten für bis zu weitere
neben den 500 die wir untergebracht
haben für bis zu weitere 500 personen
aktuell das treibt denen die helfenden
der basis schon tatsächlich den schweiß
auf die stirn schon jetzt nach drei
kriegswochen und vor der grenze stehen
zehntausende hunderttausende der
ostermann haben sie hinweise wo die
realen zahlen aktuell liegen also laut
bundesregierung haben wir im moment
etwas über 200.000 registrierte
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine haben sie
hinweise wo wir tatsächlich im moment
stehen und wie viele das werden könnten
also konkret ist es aktuell so dass
210.000 zumindest bekannte
flüchtende sich aktuell in der
bundesrepublik aufhalten die
dunkelziffer ist natürlich viel viel
höher weil wir überhaupt nicht
flächendeckend kontrollieren weil wir
überhaupt keine grenzkontrollen haben
und weil die personen die sich im inland
bewegen sich circa nach vier bis sechs
wochen erst registriert haben und dann
im nachgang die zahlen kommen also sie
hatten ja gesagt bis zu eine million ich
würde die prognose deutlich erweitern
natürlich immer abhängig von den
kriegsgeschehen in der ukraine aber das
zeigt wie massiv schnell in kürzester
zeit die zahlen angestiegen sind und wir
haben große dunkelziffer deswegen im
übrigen haben wir auch gesagt die
notifizierung der grenze für
grenzkontrollen sind zwangsläufig da
kommen wir gleich drauf hat heute berger
sie experten gehen von viel viel mehr
flüchtlingen aus das ist ja jetzt keine
horror mail um sondern einfach eine
konkrete planung worauf muss man sich
einstellen das heißt dass halten sie für
realistisch ist werden viel mehr als
eine million ja danach sieht das leider
aus mit diesem brutalen kriegsgeschehen
was putin da eröffnet hat ist die größte
fluchtbewegung nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg in europa die wir da erleben
und das hat eine große dimension deshalb
sage ich dass bei allem ich kenne die
praxis mit der erstaufnahme wie
schwierig das ist und trotzdem weil wir
werden das nicht so einfach nachholen
können deshalb betone ich dass wir
wichtig die registrierung am anfang ist
gerade damit wir die kinder und
jugendlichen die jetzt schon zu uns
kommen auch bald in bildungsangebote
bringen können und auch die erwachsenen
die jetzt gerade kommen möglichst bald
in arbeit bringen können die dürfen ja
auch schnell bei uns arbeiten dafür
müssen wir wissen wer er ist er gekommen
wenn man etwas anbieten was nach einem
traum im moment in arbeit zu bringen
aber was was doch auch dazu gehört
übrigens zu unserem migrationsdebatte in
unserem land was ich schon wahrnehmen
sind doch riesige widersprüche das
bezieht sich überhaupt nicht verlieren
feld und dieses tolle engagement aber
ich meine ich erlebt eine debatte die
letzten zwei jahre wo ständig behauptet
wurde von manchen kommunen die sich
selber als sichere häfen deklarieren und
behaupten wir haben platz und jetzt wo
sozusagen offensichtliche
kriegsflüchtlinge sind und wir akut
platz für menschen brauchen da ist er
sehr knapp also es gibt natürlich auch
einige akteure in unserer
migrationspolitischen debatte in
deutschland die da sehr unehrlich
unterwegs